Well, for
three days,
Chinese ships
and planes have been buzzing around
Taiwan and military exercises
that have raised tensions in the region.
China now says the exercises are over.
The first time ever,
it appeared to include a simulation
of a Chinese aircraft carrier
carrying out strikes on Taiwan.
More from CNN's Selena One.
China launched
three days of military exercises
around Taiwan
after the island's
president met the US House speaker
China's military said the drills create
an all around encirclement
of the island
and simulate
precision attacks on key targets.
In reaction to the military, drills,
Taiwan's Ministry of Foreign Affairs said
China's, quote,
provocative measures
have clearly challenged
the international order,
undermine peace
and stability of the Taiwan Strait
and the region.
China's fighter jets
fly around Taiwan skies.
Military ships sail off its coast.
China says it's simulating
precision attacks on key
targets in Taiwan.
So while Beijing has not launched
any missiles,
its military
released this animation
showing
missiles fired from land, sea
and air into Taiwan.
Two of them explode in flames.
Beijing is showing the world its fury
launching
three days of military exercises
around Taiwan
after the island's
president, Tsai Ing wen met with U.S.
House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy in California.
For the first time,
it appears Chinese
simulated strikes
with warplanes
that took off from an aircraft carrier.
This video shows Taiwan's coast guard
confronting a Chinese ship.
The Taiwanese
sailor says you were now
seriously damaging regional peace,
stability and safety.
Please turn around immediately.
And leave if you keep proceeding forward.
I will take eviction measures.
The encounter
highlighting the risks
of any miscalculation
in the Taiwan Street.
Beijing sees democratically ruled Taiwan
as a part of its territory
that will eventually be reunified
with the mainland
Chinese military
said the drills are, quote,
a serious warning against the Taiwan
separatist forces, collusion
with external forces,
and a necessary move to defend
national sovereignty.
Experts say Beijing
is normalizing
military activity around the island.
It already sent military jets
and ships
around Taiwan
every day on China's heavily
censored social media.
Some are commenting that
the drills do not go far enough.
One writes, Let's just take Taiwan.
Another says,
If you're not going to attack,
then don't waste taxpayer money.
Well, then U.S.
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
visited Taiwan last summer.
China
responded with military drills
that simulated a blockade.
For the first time,
China even fired
missiles over the island.
Experts say the military response to
this time is more restrained
because the meeting between
Tai and McCarthy
was held on American soil
to avoid provoking Beijing.
Today, I am honored both Washington
and Taipei have called the visit
just an ordinary transit stop.
But the symbolism was undeniable.
We are stronger when we are together
with Washington's support for Taipei
only growing.
Beijing's anger will only intensify.
On China's third
day of military exercises around
Taiwan, the US Navy sent a destroyer
close to a contested
island to the South China Sea.
Now, Beijing claims
the island is theirs
and called the move illegal.
Meanwhile, the U.S.
says it can operate
wherever international law allows.
So it's not just Taiwan,
but the South China Sea
is another source of tensions
between the US and China.
And with these latest exercises,
around Taiwan,
experts say China's
military is flexing
its military might,
showing the world
that it has the ability
to conduct blockade
and missile
strikes on targets in and around Taiwan.
Charlene Wang, CNN, Beijing.